[Musique]
au sommaire de Peter bot au Pavillon par
h la curiosité de la semaine les termes
de
[Musique]
silaos rendez-vous sur la route de
silaos juste avant d'arriver à peterbot
vous pourrez vous garer en bord de route
à côté du départ du
[Musique]
sentier pour cette randonnée facile de 6
km prévoir de bonnes chaussures de quoi
vous protéger de la pluie et du soleil
et une réserve
d'eau pour votre santé parcourez nos
sentiers
moins connu que la partie haute du
cirque de silaos dont les sentiers
permettent de monter au python des
neiges ou de se rendre vers mafat la
partie basse à l'entrée du cirque
propose pourtant quelques sentiers qui
méritent aussi le détour comme celui que
nous empruntons aujourd'hui qui relie
Peter bot au pavillon dans le sens de la
descente il permet de rejoindre en
douceur le petit bras de silaos tout en
profitant de beau points de vue sur le
rempart du
dimitil P est dans la mer
à 600 m d'altitude la végétation diffère
de celle du plateau de silaos J 600 m
plus
[Musique]
haut dans cette forêt semièche beaucoup
d'exotiques sont présentes comme ce faux
poivrier dont les BA sont très
[Musique]
prisé seule que nous croiserons est
celle du sentier qui rejoint palmiste
rouge attention il est actuellement
[Musique]
fermé la traversée du petit bras de
silaos apporte un peu de fraîcheur un
endroit où il fait bon s'arrêter comme
certains l'ont fait avant nous
malheureusement sans respecter les lieux
ouais ben tu vois voilà un camp c'est
assez habituel côté des rivières là on
se retrouve en présence d'un camp comme
il y a beaucoup d' silaos au bord des
rivières hein très souvent on trouve des
camps comme ça celui-ci il est assez
joli hein avec son sa petite cabane en
Choka un camp comme ça on le laisse hein
autant les bâches on les enlève mais un
camp comme ça on le laisse il y a pas de
souci maintenant ce site va est utilisé
pour pour bivoaker ce qui en soi ne pose
pas de souci mais par contre le le le
dépôt de déchet vraiment c'est c'est pas
bon quoi la remontée sur l'autre versant
commence dans une ambiance plus sauvage
c'est sans compter sur le travail des
forestiers justement présent ce jour-là
pour nettoyer le sentier la différence
en ressent immédiatement la suite du
sentier est propre et bien dégagé preuve
que ce travail fastidieux d'entretien
régulier est primordial pour profiter au
au mieux des beautés de notre
[Musique]
île mais il n'y a pas que la végétation
qui évolue vite dans certaines zones ce
sont carrément les roches très friables
comme ici qui peuvent provoquer des
éboulies ah ouais donc là tu vois ouais
ça c'est ce que je te disais tout à
l'heure c'est que c'est que là toute
cette roche là c'est la matière qui a
été remobilisée c'est tombé de la
montagne c'est de la roche en fait qui a
aucune tenue qui est hyper friable qui a
été abîmée par l'eau par l'eau la vapeur
dos hein au moment des des éruptions et
qui est qui qui est vraiment en très
mauvais état donc là on marche là-dessus
rien ne tient là-dessus absolument rien
ne
[Musique]
tient
à la plom du dimiti le plateau dil Hute
est bien fourni en source d'eau ce qui a
permis l'installation d'un petite Hette
composé de moins d'une dizaine de cases
il règne ici une ambiance particulière
cette Hette étant l'un des seuls assyos
à ne pas être raccordé à une
route pourtant cette dernière n'est pas
loin à peine le col passé pour
redescendre vers le pavillon les rumeurs
de circulation se font
entendre
[Musique]
à l'ombre des fil à haut la descente est
rapide et l'on retrouve le petit bras de
silaos juste avant qu'il ne rejoigne le
grand
[Musique]
bras arrivé au Pavillon vous pourrez
revenir sur vos pas ou récupérer une
autre voiture que vous aurez garé
[Musique]
ici ce que j'aime sur ce sentier c'est
la traversée d'iletot donc là il y a une
ambiance un petit peu à la mafat
c'est-à-dire que on arrive par un
sentier et on se retrouve avec des
petites maisons nichées dans la
végétation c'est un sentier qui est
assez peu fréquenté mais qui en fait
offre un large panorama à partir du Sud
du cirque donc c'est un point de vue
qu'on a pas l'habitude de voir on a un
point de vue sur la chaîne de Peter bot
quasiment jusqu'au bonnet de prêtre
palmiste rouge logé entre ces montagnes
c'est c'est c'est vraiment agréable
ouais ce que j'aime moins ça serait pl
plôt la partie qui redescend justement
sur pavillon parce que là on se retrouve
dans une ambiance très bruillante de
route avec le passage de pavillon c'est
un endroit où les gens cllaxonnent
beaucoup parce qu'il y a des a des
virages et donc là c'est c'est moins
agréable cette
[Musique]
partie plusieurs fois détru et
reconstruite au siècle dernier les
termes de silaos aujourd'hui positionnés
à l'entrée nord du village sont notre
curiosité de la semaine cette est unique
c'est la seule station thermale qui
existe dans l'océan Indien est situé à
silaos ça a commencé aux anciens termes
dans les
années 60 65 ça a démarré et puis depuis
987 1987 c'est l'établissement termal la
C qui est ouvert aujourd'hui le bâtiment
a une plus grande capacité d'accueil
c'est un véritable s de soins avec
curistes et on fait aussi la remise en
forme vous avez deux s exploitbles vous
avez celle Véronique qui ser 31 deg à 10
m C qui c'est à la mise en bouteille de
l'eau de silos et iré à 37 de et à 8 m c
t les installations d'ici sont alimentés
par la sace hé propriételle est très
fugineuse et en ver de ça c'est pour
lesécur qui so so l'arrose le rhumatisme
on fait aussi la CU
digestive ça fait 25 ans que nous on
fait on est dans la partie technique et
qu'on gère ça au quotidien le soucis
c'est que tout la se bouche avec le fer
et nous notre travail à nous c'est
vraiment maintenir toutes les instations
en marche normale toujours tous les
jours on contact c'est tous les jours
comme ça c'est toute une vie c'est une
deème femme on va
[Musique]
dire